Ragnarok is coming the water and all
wars and it's up to Kratos and atreus to
uncover answers about how to put a stop
to it or at the very least survive it
and so in order to help we've put
together our best spoiler-free tips for
God of War Ragnarok there are a lot of
sections in the game that see Kratos and
atreus take to the water in a canoe
during these segments keep an eye out
for barrels and shimmering golden areas
as these both will contain hack silver
or crafting materials crashing into a
barrel will net you the items
immediately while you'll need to press a
button to pick up loot from the
shimmering locations Additionally you
may periodically notice Dew drops
hanging from tree limbs in the water and
interacting with these will earn you
permanent stat boosts so never pass them
up just like in the first game Odin has
sent Ravens throughout the nine Realms
to keep an eye on you these green
spectral birds fly around or perch on
objects in each realm and they generally
though not always take some pretty good
awareness to spot however you can also
identify when one is nearby due to the
unique screeching they emit
when you hear one start looking up and
around to see if you can find and
destroy it with your ex as you destroy
more and more of these make sure you
visit niflheim and head over to the crow
tree to unlock chests that contain some
really great gear
foreign speaking of niffelheim you'll
gain access to this realm relatively
early in your adventure and it can be a
useful place to hang out if you're the
type who likes to train and work on your
moves in addition to housing the
aforementioned Crow tree it also Sports
a training area where you can practice
Combos and learn the best ways of using
any skills you've recently unlocked with
multiple types of enemies to fight
against endlessly you can Master any
goals you set your mind to here but just
remember that you won't gain XP for any
of it
combat can get pretty hectic in God of
War Ragnarok so you'll need all the help
you can get just like in God of War by
pressing the square button you can have
atreus fire arrows at your enemies for
you dealing some damage and building up
an enemy's stun bar more rapidly arrows
recharge quickly too so make sure to
consistently combo them with your own
barrage of melee attacks and then follow
up with devastating stun grabs to finish
off your foes additionally a tracer's
ranged attacks come in handy against
small creatures and flying enemies like
nightmares both of which can be a little
more difficult for Kratos to land melee
hits on it doesn't matter how good you
are about picking up the stuff enemies
drop after battles you're almost
guaranteed to overlook something
valuable here and there early in the
game Brock will introduce you to a chest
beside his Forge where he keeps all of
the items you've left behind on your
travels anytime you approach a forged
throughout the game the chest will be
closed and glow blue when there's
something to grab from it usually
crafting materials you didn't see after
a combat encounter be sure to check it
regularly to be sure you're not missing
anything that could be useful to you on
your journey as you find weapon upgrades
during exploration you can use them at
the forge to gain a new weapon level and
unlock some new skills for each Armament
since you'll be leveling your weapons
multiple times there are plenty of
skills for Kratos and atreus to unlock
throughout the game's lengthy campaign
and you can feel free to buy them in any
order really as long as you're
completing at least some of the side
quests and exploring thoroughly you'll
have a constant influx of XP that will
ensure that you can purchase most of the
skills available at any one point in the
story because of this you're usually
only ever an hour or so away from buying
whichever skill you've got your eyes on
so spend your XP freely and don't worry
too much the armor relics and weapon
hilts that you pick will largely depend
on your preferred play style and you
have the opt option to upgrade them
using materials gained while exploring
completing quests and defeating enemies
the further you progress in the game the
higher enemies levels will become so if
you forget to keep up your gear levels
you may find yourself against those who
can kill you very quickly even in a
single hit sometimes check with Brock
and syndra at regular intervals to
upgrade anything you've settled on but
don't be afraid to switch things up as
needed either because you're quite
likely to be overflowing with hack
silver and lower tier materials
throughout most of the game you'll find
Narnia chests in most Realms which
require you to engage with or destroy
three nearby runes to open
huh
these runes usually take a bit of
Ingenuity to find and may require you to
position yourself somewhere specific
burn away branches or engage with other
mechanics that become available to you
later in your journey it's always worth
the hassle to find them and unlock the
chest though as doing so will provide
you with the items needed to permanently
upgrade your health and rage
As you move through each of the Realms
you're going to find artifacts often in
the form of books and poems that can be
sold to Brock and cindery for a nice
chunk of change most of them prompt some
funny conversations with mamir and a few
of them are even related to quests don't
worry though selling them won't impact
your progress with a collection and that
extra hack silver your pocket can Aid
you with upgrades and more
after obtaining two moosefullheim seed
Hobs and combining them together you'll
be able to travel to musfelheim like in
the first game this realm features a
selection of combat challenges that
reward you with loot when completed if
you want to max out your armor levels
and earn some new ways to customize your
build this will be a necessary part of
your adventure and due to the fact that
you'll need to complete and recomplete
challenge rooms in specific orders to
unlock the final six challenges you're
likely to spend quite a few hours here
figuring it all out
there is a bevy of accessibility
features that allow you to customize
your experience to meet your unique
needs including options for Low Vision
hearing motor motion options and much
more even if you don't require some of
the more in-depth features you can use
the menu to customize things like Auto
pickup and whether you have to tap or
hold a button During certain actions so
don't pass up an opportunity to improve
your experience however you see fit one
of my personal favorites is mini boss
checkpointing which adds checkpoints to
tricky mini bosses that might be
blocking your progress make sure to
check out our God of War Ragnarok review
right here on Gamespot And subscribe for
more on the game including our lore
Series where we break down the major
players in Norse mythology or our deep
dives into the history of the series and
its complete timeline thanks for
watching and we'll catch you next time